esta madrugada Rusia volvía a atacar
Ucrania pero especialmente kiev la
capital con una ola de drones no
solamente
shaj hits O kamikaz sino también de
reconocimiento y como ya suele ser
costumbre desde comienzos del mes de
mayo que se han reactivado esos ataques
con gran intensidad solo cuatro en la
última semana las defensas aéreas se
activaron y lograron derribar estos 20
aeronaves no tripuladas pero tienen
grandes consecuencias para la la
población estamos en un conjunto
Residencial bastante grande en la ciudad
y este edificio que está a mis espaldas
uno de los tantos que hay aquí aquí cayó
una de esas partes del dron en el techo
del edificio prendiendo fuego y los
cuatro apartamentos que estaban en ese
piso quedaron afectados hemos estado
allí y hemos visto por ejemplo como
partes de esos apartamentos quedaron el
techo quedó totalmente derribado está
lleno de de agua porque obviamente las
tuberías se rompieron y también veíamos
parte de la realidad de lo que es este
país uno de esos apartamentos estaba
desocupado porque sus dueños están en el
extranjero pero aún así la comunidad
entró y está ayudándoles a reparar su
piso y nos encontrábamos con otra mujer
que sí estaba en el apartamento
afortunadamente salió ilesa más allá del
susto su apartamento está muy dañado nos
decía que no quería hablar con la prensa
pero que tenía el corazón totalmente
dolido la vimos luego salir con unas
bolsas de plástico llevando algunos de
los objetos que tenía y luego ya nos
contó fuera de cámaras que estaba
buscando refugio en casa de unos amigos
porque no podía vivir allí el olor ha
quemado en esa parte es bastante grande
pero también lo que hemos visto aquí
Como sucede suceder en Ucrania en todas
partes donde hay un ataque es la
comunidad yendo a que hay decenas de
personas que han venido a ayudar bajando
los escombros trayéndoles comida y
apoyando a volver a restablecer cierta
normalidad en la ciudad o especialmente
en este lugar